how do Luxury companies get to the point
that those products are so valuable it
intrigues me actually
because there are two kind of mindsets
in the world which is if anything's very
good it should be made abundant and
everybody should have the French tend
have a mindset that anything that's any
good has to be unbelievably scarce there
will always be some very rich people who
wish to practice costly signaling what
are your thoughts on the ethics of
marketing there's a kind of which
apparently happens in luxury goods
stores where you get extremely
attractive women to actually be slightly
rude to the customers and then the older
slightly less attracted women are so
Keen to make their point that they buy
something really expensive that's funny
it is just really really interesting
when you understand the extent to which
of course human behavior is mediated by
the imagined opinions of
[Music]
others Rory southernland welcome to my
podcast that's pleasure thank you very
much for inviting me on thank you very
much for taking the time to come on I
have so many questions about marketing
for you and psychology I think this
could be a very interesting conversation
hopefully I hope so yes I think it's um
to be honest I think the fundamental
observation that goes through all my
books my writing is fundamentally quite
benal of what is interesting to me is
that it comes as so much as a surprise
to most people reading it
uh the idea that actually you know at
some fundamental level perception is
reality in that we behave in response to
what we perceive uh rather than what is
factually or objectively accurate and
therefore you know there are certain as
aspect of problem solving in human
behavior where some marketing Le
approach is inescapable that seems to be
basically self-evident but it comes as a
complete surprise to people in Fields as
versus economics or politics who see it
as their obvious duty to improve
objective reality um uh with complete
disregard for how the actual change or
the uh the input is perceived which
seems to be fundamentally
OD that yes this is true do you do you
think there are personality traits that
play into the role of how good people
are naturally at marketing well I think
there's an interesting one which is
there's a fundament distinction which is
I don't think you're a very good
marketer if you're highly
dogmatic uh if you insist on having a
one siiz fits all uh
Dogma
or I suppose yeah you might almost call
it you know a litany or religion that
explains everything okay and you're
unhappy to consider contextual variation
in things then you're not going to be a
good marketer and it worries me to an
extent that what our education system
seems to do is it selects for people who
can win arguments rather than solve
problems and it strikes me that the act
of solving problems is fundamentally
Messier more experimental more creative
and less
certain than the kill kit you require to
win an argument which is effectively
construct an artificial model uh win the
argument for the model and then walk
away s satisfied regardless of how
applicable that solution might be in
reality and so it does bother me a
little bit because it strikes me that we
probably have a governmental class the
administrative class in business which
has been selected for its ability to
look
coherent uh and to maintain logical
consistency rather than uh the rather
more important question of whether you
solve problems or not in
reality you guys may or may not know
I launched a hangover supplement called
Afterparty which you can get at Fuller
health.com linked Below in the comments
it works by breaking down AET alahh
which is responsible for poisoning you
after drinking nobody likes waking up
with the feeling of Hangover with nausea
headaches and other symptoms and Di
Hydro myice tin main ingredient is
backed by peer-reviewed studies not that
I normally believe most studies but
these are legit studies done on rats uh
all the studies are linked on my website
at Fuller health.com if you want to nerd
out but it helps reduce alcohol damage
obviously this is an ad to encourage you
to drink it's not good for you period I
don't even think the small amounts that
they say are good for you are good for
you but if you do have the occasional
glasses of wine or beer or for me vodka
soda this can go a long way in
preventing damage to your overall health
and making you more productive the next
day which is what I'm about can't take
any days off work if want and get ahead
in life it literally reduces my
hangovers by about 80% so I can work
normally let me know what you think
there's a 30-day money back guarantee so
you can try them even if you're
skeptical no strings attached I will
give you your money back if you don't
like them because you'll like them go to
Fuller health.com code MP for 15% off
linked in the comments enjoy the rest of
this
episode so do you think this is
something somebody can be taught in
University like is going to get a
marketing degree that's something people
can do and then be
successful interesting question I I mean
some large part of it I think uh is if
not innate and it may not be innate at
all but it is a kind of tacit scale in
that it's not completely teachable that
it requires if you like a refinement of
instinct rather than what you might call
um hard teaching it's it's one of those
many fact most of human behavior is
actually driven by passid learned
experience which isn't necessarily
explainable or teachable you know great
example is reversing an you if you're
reversing a semi into a narrow gate or
opening now a lorry driver truck driver
is going to be better at that than the
professor of engineering at um Yale okay
yeah that's because it's really much
more a kind of learned instinctive skill
the words of someone on Clarkson's far
I can't tell you how to do it you just
have to know and I think you know a
large part of marketing is probably um T
it it involves as I said you know the
refinement of certain
instinctive qualities rather than
something and in fact I would argue that
people who insist on having a process
and an absolutely rigid procedure before
they can start work on anything probably
aren't very good
marketers that's always you know that's
always the worry if you ever have a
problem and the first person the first
thing the person wants to know are costs
and timings you're probably not cut out
for this
business and probably you know this is
connected to it's not it's not
exclusively about creativity and other
skills like humor uh you know again
humor being you know something
incredibly C it as a scale yeah um it's
connected to that but there's very
experiment in John C's excellent book
which is called creativity a short and
cheerful guy he advances some evidence
that uh they take a group of Architects
who are highly prized for their
creativity and Imagination and they
compare them to a group of Architects in
their working methods who have been
nominated by their peers anonymously as
being worker day extraordinarily
uncreative generally uninteresting
Architects and the one of the patterns
in their work working Behavior which
completely bated between the two groups
was that the uncreative architect
started work straight away and the CRA
architect kind of had a weird fallow
period where to put it one way they they
understood that the art of coming up
with an idea was not something you can
force and what they were doing in the S
was waiting to get lucky they were
waiting for inspiration strike something
of that
kind okay that's because we we have a we
have a world which is obsessed with kind
of what you might call nominal
productivity which kind of prizes being
busy at all
costs and one of the things that you
know the great John lenon quote time
spent doing nothing is very rarely
wasted and I think he knew whereof he
spoke in the sense that some degree of
discretionary uninterrupted time is
probably essential to any really
significant kind of mental progress now
don't get me wrong in a for this
production line when you want to do
exactly the same thing Time After Time
After Time you can narrow it down to an
optimal process I I don't think you can
do that with any kind of creative act uh
the best you can do is just increase the
odds of getting lucky the great great
book on this uh by the way by Rick Rubin
which is called the the creative act
aware of being I was on Rick's podcast a
few weeks ago and was generally uh
extremely uh enthused by reading his
book beforehand it's a very very good
take on you know quite a lot of the
behavior that I think is involved in uh
creativity is in a way it's as I said
it's it's not only non-logical it's
sometimes
paradoxical and by way there are lots of
fields of activity that work this way in
fact I would I would argue that the
majority of human decision making has to
work this way because what we consider
to be
science uh where you have all the
information you need to arrive at a
single right answer where the relations
between the different variables are all
set in stone and where the laws cannot
change okay that's a very very narrow
subset of problem solving yeah there are
special cases okay we know the
relationship between air pressure the
boiling point of water and the amount of
energy required to heat water to boiling
point and so you can Pro provide an
exact calculation there partly because
all the data is
commensurable you know the relationship
between all the data it's exact and it
doesn't and it's Eternal you know I
assume so anyway as far as we know you
know there's a Newtonian component to
the world where the laws seem to be
pretty much written in stone yeah just
real world problems and nothing of that
kind and yet what we tend to do is we
pretend they are and high used to talk
about scientism which is the use of
methodologies and patterns of thought
derived from the Harden physical
sciences and then their application for
reasons of credibility or indeed winning
an argument to fields in which they're
entirely
inappropriate and I think that's an
interesting point because an awful lot
of human effort nowadays seems to be
dedicated to making things look
scientific even though that probably
isn't the habit of thought you need to
the problem in the first
place yes I think the concept of
scientism is interesting because it you
know there isn't really there are
certain words which always bother me
because there's a vocabulary problem in
that the opposite of rational is
irrational which is
automatically assumed to be a term of
appropriate you are being
completely okay IE stupid or foolish
okay so there isn't really a proper term
for hyper rational for example there
isn't really a term of criticism that
applies to uh things that look rational
but really aren't and there isn't really
a term of criticism for things well I
mean h use scientism but then how what's
the noun you create from that
scientistic is the adjective I guess
what are you if you practice that a
scienti I don't know but it's a very
useful term but it never took off um and
that really is the appearance of looking
scientific um in uh effectively uh
solving problems which don't really
submit to the same conditions in which
you can practice the scientific method
medicine's kind of interesting because
it's is it a science or is it a craft
well it's kind of a
mixture yeah okay that's fascinating uh
you talked a little bit about luck so I
have I've got a bit of experience with
marketing and we're building an app
which I told you about offline uh
Peterson academ for for online courses
and I realized I think a couple years
ago that I couldn't sit cuz I'm pretty
work oriented so I like to sit down and
solve problems and I realized for
developing something new I did have to
kind of wait and sometimes I'd wake up
in the middle of the night and go oh
here's the idea finally but there was no
point in sitting down and forcing it
because it just didn't work I just had
to wait and sometimes it would take
months and I'd be like I'll figure it
out something will click eventually and
I'll figure it out so I so I get what
you're saying about waiting but you
mentioned luck um is there any way
to increase that or kind of hone those
skills yeah I think I think there are
patterns of behavior you can adopt and
there are mindsets you can adopt which
is almost the act of distracting
yourself or listening to the unconscious
voice I mean a very boring one which is
commonly um uh Advanced is the overnight
test you know if you think about
something you sleep on it and the
following morning you know may maybe you
have a further bout of inspiration or
maybe you realized the idea was kind of
dumb all
along there are interesting there are
interesting patterns of decisionmaking
the one I'm very fond of mentioned by
Herodotus is that the ancient Persians
when they had to debate any matter of
import they debated it twice once when
sober and once when drunk and it was
only when they agreed in both states
that they actually adopted the action so
if it didn't appeal to the drunk and in
other words if it didn't in a sense have
an emotional appeal to them um and it
also so it had to meet two tests in the
same way I suppose the jury system is
interesting in uh in Anglo-Saxon law in
that you have to convince not only legal
experts that there is a case to answer
but you have to convince a you know a
representative body of people that what
you're saying is just fundamentally
believable and indeed reasonable but I
had a friend who was on jury where the
person was in strictly legal terms
guilty of the crime for which they were
charged but the jury agreed that given
the provocation their behavior was
entirely understandable and they
basically let them off that's not
supposed to work like that but it's
similar to that Persian question where
you look at the same thing in two
different modes context settings or
whatever
and it's by the way it's a great
disadvantage which creativity suffers
from so I always make the point that
there is in uh in any kind of
institutional setting there's this
asymmetry where creative people have to
present their ideas to rational people
for approval but it doesn't really
happen the other way around you don't
get a bunch of account SC well we've
come to the conclusion that it's 3.7
million but before we actually make that
decision or write the check we're going
to share our ideas with really wacky
people to see if they've got an
alternative idea you don't get Engineers
going well we want to make the train
faster what about you what would you do
okay yeah because within any kind of
rational
self-contained model of the world it's
effectively self- sustaining whereas
creativity isn't self- sustaining you've
always got to win some battle somewhere
else before you're allowed to act and it
seems to me that that asymmetry is kind
of problematic and that I mean if you
want to get really deep in this I don't
know how whether you or indeed your dad
have ever met um Ian mcgilchrist the
author of The Master and hisry yeah
definitely that that that's if you like
the vastly more philosophical and
neuroscientific um take on what I'm
saying that there's a natural balance
between effectively left hemisphere
right hemisphere modes of seeing the
world in which in many many settings
probably because of the need to win
arguments by the way that's one reason
the left hemisphere view of the world
artificially is allowed to
predominate huh that would be take on it
yeah that there's there's a fundamental
problem with I with with good ideas
which is that they're often late to the
party in that the ration what what
appears rational and consistent has an
instantaneous
appeal whereas the better idea first of
all takes time to be accepted but also
takes time to be generated in many cases
you know that I mean there are cases in
point where you know I was given a brief
and you know in the advertising world
and being candid this happens I failed
completely and then six months later
inspiration struck I go oh God why the
hell did I think of that then but the
simple fact is I didn't because there's
a kind of probabilistic I I'll tell you
a little story which I I shared with
Rick Rubin as well which was I've got a
friend who runs a business called aore
doio which I jokingly call Air B2B
because it's effectively uh home rental
for homes where people intend to
work so every every home of your rent
will be kitted out with two retina
screens two very good desks two
ergonomic chairs an espresso machine and
it'll have hot Wi-Fi and probably
electric car charging okay
it's going BB for a particular
application and I said look I can't
think of anything that will help you
advertise your product but if I get
lucky I'll let you know okay and about
six months after I was aware of this
business I was staying in a hotel room
with my wife and it was actually my
wife's observation not mine well she
said why is it which is a brilliant
brilliant piece of observation which had
never occurred why is it that hotels
have this sexist idea that only one
party in the room will want to use a
desk okay so there's this fundamental
sexism in hotel rooms which is there's a
chap signing million dollar check
sitting at the kind of Napoleonic scale
death whereas meanwhile his lady wife is
in the bathroom kind of you know
powdering her face or you know putting
on a poka dot bow you know this about
1950s conception of what a what a
partnership is like and F enough I mean
there's a reason my wife noticed this
cuz I think I was hogging the desk and
she was forced to spraw sprawl on some
totally inappropriate item of furniture
while trying to CH and I said thank you
because you've just solved the problem
for a sure and the basic question is
which is a very good question how come
hotel rooms have two wash basins and
only one
death I mean you spend a hell of a lot
longer typing than you knew cleaning
your teeth but for some weird reason
they've decided that two wash basins
absolute essential okay but but one desk
is absolutely
fine and so that's I say you know in
many cases you've just got to wait to
get lucky and the reason is often I
think there are several reasons some
ideas arise through um a different a
very difficult form of observation which
is the dog that doesn't bark in the
night in other words you have to notice
the absence I you must know the Sherlock
Holmes story I hope you are were versed
in the um what holes notices is that the
theft of a race force is probably an
inside job because the dog didn't bark
now that is if you like not a data point
it's actually the absence of an expected
data point which is hard to
notice um Often by the way Often by the
way ideas that generate uh interesting
uh things arrive anecdotally they're
surprisingly tangential or irrelevant
the the inspiration you get is um in a
sense is is is not something that arises
when you're actively looking for it it's
almost in some ways creative ideas are
almost the act of distracting
yourself um I do have a kind of favored
thing which is that I noticed that
you're more likely to have um an idea or
an inspiration when you're in a lional
point so in other words if you go from
doing one thing to another now it it
just to make that point Archimedes
didn't have the idea sitting in the bath
as is commonly believed he had the idea
when he got into the
bath and you know one one of the things
I quite like about working from Power
inable working is that um when you have
10 minutes to spare at home you go and
put the dishwasher on you do something
entirely different okay and weirdly it's
at the moment when you flip from one
mode of activity to another that
inspiration is more likely to strike I
think so you know I think there are
tools I think you can improve the Arts I
think you can to borrow a kind of the
talad phrase you could increase your
surface area exposure to possible upside
optionality okay I think you can do that
but you can't necessarily force
it okay I like that I think I feel like
I've noticed the same thing I have like
in my life I have a number of different
projects going on and I need a number of
different projects because if I only
have one I'm bored and it just tortures
me so I have way too many things going
on so I can work on one and say okay I'm
done I'm tapped out here and move on to
the other one and then move on to the
other one is there like for for people
who are inclined to go into marketing do
you think there's an optimal number of
projects they could work on at the same
time so they'd be switching tasks it's
interesting because one of the reasons
for the existence of for example the
advertising agency as an entity is that
there's a certain sort of person who
would find it painful to work on one
thing all the
time so there's a certain kind of
mindset which thrives on variety which
an agency provides which working in the
house may not generally I'd say working
in marketing in the house will provide
you with a hell of a lot more variety
than but having an act jury or something
um you know I would recommend it for
people of a particular mindset if you
can cope with and thrive on and even
relish a certain degree of mess if
you're obsessed if you're obsessed with
if you're obsessed with having a
universal framework which answers all
questions go to become an economist or
something dangerous like that instead
you know but if you actually are happy
with the fact that um correct answers
are scale and context dependent and that
psychology is a deeply perverse thing
where the opposite of a good idea can be
another good idea if you're comfortable
with that kind of thing then i' highly
recommend it what worries me a little
bit is no yeah I i' I've spent 30 years
in advertising I think advertising is
actually probably a bit more important
than people think and it's qu it's
highly entertaining and very
enjoyable what started to worry me is it
what's significant about an advertising
agency and some extent marketing as well
in general is there are very very few
modes of employment in which this type
of thinking is incouraged rewarded or
tolerated okay so once J said that the
great thing about working in advertising
agency is the one job where you can make
a DFT suggestion and still get
promoted because something that's
interesting eccentric counterintuitive
or odd is prized in that atmosphere and
encouraged and rewarded in a way that
it's often punished anywhere else you
know in many other forms of employment
you'd be seen as you know fundamentally
Whimsical and not a safe of hands
now you know to Echo mcil Christ what
worries me I know him quite well
actually he's a great guy what what he's
actually interestingly quite interested
in advertising for this reason in that
there are worryingly few areas of
activity where that kind of creative
thought is properly rewarded or
encouraged I think because in many ways
you know there's a you know great any
good creative person will have some very
strange acutes they don't really have a
sense of proportion because they know
that inspiration is just as likely to
come from something trivial or something
big you know noticing the two words
sound similar okay which is you know
seemingly irrelevant can be a
breakthrough in that kind of problem
solving and it do it does worry me that
if you like that politics doesn't really
have a cretive department that you know
that
actually a a sensible healthy
organization would encourage a degree of
what you might call at least creative
descent from the mainstream
narrative and yeah I jokingly said look
if I'd been in charge of of an
investment Bank in
2007 okay um I would have been fired
long beforehand as an appalling person
to run an investment bank but the one
thing I would have done is I would have
been immune from the financial crisis
because in my outer office I would have
employed sort of three marxists or
Austrian School economists or anybody
who effectively had a Counterpoint to
what was an overdominant kind of
narrative of uh effectively A
self-confirming Narrative of how the
economy
Works um and so you know I I think I
think there is a you know there's a
natural kind of perversity there's a
lack of sense of proportion in Creative
people there's kind of whimsicality
there's a reluctance to get started all
those things I think are a virtue in a
creative setting but not a great career
move in most forms of
employment
yeah this is this is definitely true I
think I was probably just fortunate
choosing I I had like a a normal job
that was very rational and then I kind
of did the creative things on the side
until they grew enough to to
overtake which I'm I'm happy about I'm
grateful for I have a question that's
completely unrelated to what we were
talking about I've always I've I've
always wondered how do Luxury companies
get to the point like say Hermes for
example how do they get to the point
that those products are so
valuable are they all doing something
similar I mean There are rules you can't
break I mean one of the things which of
course is interesting is that many of
them are privately
owned uh there's a very interesting
thing which is that I think there are
two there are two kind of mindsets in
the world which is the Anglo-Saxon work
which you find in North America which is
anything's very good it should be made
abundant and everybody should have it
which is why the United States produced
Coke okay you know as said all the cokes
are the same and all the co Cokes are
good and the president of the United
States can't get a better Coke than the
bum on the corner of the street okay and
for a long time particularly now the
French T have a mindset that anything
that's any good has to be unbelievably
scarce okay ah okay one of the things
that both threaten you know snobby
French bastards combined with a
privately owned company have an
advantage is that they they resist the
temptation to
overproduce now it also helps if you've
been doing it for a 100 years if you
have an extraordinary of Heritage and
authenticity it also requires remarkable
creative Talent over long periods I'm
not suggesting easy but it is a kind of
fascinating fact that of the most
valuable companies in the world
certainly the ones that are most
profitable in terms of margins if you
discount one or two pharmaceutical firms
and apple the rest of them tend to be
luxury goods businesses but it's also
not a bad business to be in in one
respect okay uh in that whatever happens
in the world economy and this applies by
the way even under communism okay
whatever happens politically there will
always be some very rich people who wish
to practice costly singling you also
have the advantage you also costly
singling right it's a concept from
biology originally from an is biologist
called amot zahavi to explain things
like the peacock's tale which is that
effectively a costly signal is one which
is a is a reliable indicator of Fitness
because you couldn't afford to carry
this decorative baggage around on your
back if you weren a pretty fit peacock
to begin with okay elk aners are another
example in other words there are things
that actually grow the guy to read here
is a brilliant um econ well econ
naturalist called Robert H Frank who's
written a book called The Darwin economy
but a large part of human consumption is
actually positional it's not really
about utility at all it's about your
relative position and
status and of course certain things
demonstrate um status very reliably
because they certain things demonstrate
wealth very well Because unless you were
Rich you couldn't afford to do them you
know and so you might argue that
sporting ability is a form of costly
signal because it's a reliable indicator
of your
Fitness and so that's as distinct from
cheap talk which is merely an
unsubstantiated claim a costly signal is
kind of a proof point now you know we we
use this kind of mechanism all the time
I guarantee for example that you have
never left a FedEx or UPS envelope
velope unopened on your desk for 3 Days
okay because your inference is someone
spent $20 to send me something therefore
I can infer from that that it's
something of reasonable
importance okay you know when you send
out a wedding invitation you don't do it
by email you know there are all these
kind of ways in which we signal through
discretionary effort discretionary
expenditure discretionary attention to
detail you know discretionary
perfectionism you know the things that
are difficult to do just carry more
informational Freight than things that
are easy to do yes same exent good
manners is really the display of
discretionary effort you know um and so
costly signaling is something which you
know exists in the Animal World um
actually exists in flowers uh
interestingly in the sense that uh bees
tend to be more attracted to plants with
larger flowers on the ground that you
wouldn't bother spending all that money
advertising your wees if you didn't have
quite a lot of
nectar because if you did false
advertising where you had very big
petals but no nectar you wouldn't get
any repeat business and so your
investment in flowers would not in
petals would not be repaid and so
hummingbirds certainly I think use this
as an inference point which is the more
you spend on advertising in this case
petals the more likely it is you have
something worthwhile and so that you
know that's another form of reliable
costly signal but luxury goods really
cater for people's positional
urges um and you know one of the things
are you know those bags are not only
rare and expensive by the way if you
want to buy a Kelly bag they won't even
sell you one until you've established
your Bona Ides with the luxury goods
retailer by buying a whole load of other
products which can't be resell at a
profit so if you try and just go in and
buy one
I think there was an incid with Oprah
where she complained about sort of
racist treatment um from a luxury goods
bag store in Switzerland
okay I'm not sure it was actually
because I mean uh any person working in
one of those uh stores would learn
fairly quickly I would have thought not
to discriminate by race because there
are very very rich people of all
ethnicities you know whatever you think
there there are dly forms of ethnic
inequality and wealth at the aggregate
level but there are very very rich
people in all ethnic
groups and I suspect what that was was
genuinely something like that going on
which is you make the product difficult
to
buy um there's a kind of game which
apparently happens in luxury good stores
where you get extremely attractive women
to actually be slightly rude to the
customers and then the older slightly
less attractive women are so Keen to
make their point that they buy something
really expensive in a kind of pretty
woman kind of gesture you know you know
you you've dissed me to now humiliate
you bizar I'm going to buy off the
content
of wow this is the kind of weird
gamesmanship this is why would say the
opposite of a good idea can be another
good idea because in many fields really
good friendly customer service is a
great thing to recommend in other fields
weirdly it pays to be bizarrely
disdainful and disrespectful of your
target audience okay so this is why it's
so fascinating because context changes
perception I mean effectively our our
behavior is driven by our feelings our
feelings are driven by our perception
and our perception is driven by
context and so if you can if you change
the context in which someone sees the
same thing they perceive it and
emotionally respond completely
differently now I'll give you a lovely
example of this which I only learned
today which is there was a Dominican and
a
Jesuit who both wanted to know the
answer to the question secretly hoping
it'll be yes uh can I smoke when I'm
praying and the Dominican comes back and
says I asked my Abbot or whoever it was
okay can I smoke when I'm praying and he
said no he said oh mine's fine with it
the Jesuit replied said what did you ask
I said can I smoke when I'm praying I
was told no he saidou are asked the
wrong question he said you should have
asked the question can I pray while I'm
smoking he's fine with that so that's an
example of how contextual reframing
completely changes a our
response that's funny I I I didn't think
I I mean I I know now that you've said
it but there's definitely a pattern
between American brands and mass
marketing and European Brands and very
Niche marketing making products
difficult to buy that is definitely a
European thing I mean it's interesting
that American luxury Brands like Tumi
for example pretend not to be American
and a thought Got Away In some cases is
not an American brand I didn't know that
I assumed that was Italian or something
yeah it's actually American um but
there's a general pattern where the
French are very the French in anything
food stuffs whatever they believe that
scarcity and quality wine obviously are
basically intimately connected where the
Americans have much more of a forest
mentality which is if if this is any
good we should produce L of it that's
partly the difference of having a market
of 350 million people you know and so on
but the clever thing of course about
being a luxury goods maker is whatever
the economy does they will always be
absurdly rich people who will
want these
markers now there's going to be there's
a lot of talking I I don't know if
you're a fan of
succession I love that show the dialogue
is just beautiful L it I'm not a fash
Easter as you've probably guessed from
just looking at me but apparently
there's a lot of kind of Max Mara and
stuff like that that's worn by a kind of
billionaire class which wants to Signal
quiet wealth and those kind of you know
those kind of cashmere zipneck things
that yeah Logan Roy used to wear all
that stuff and so you know you do need a
multiple Brands depending on what the
person is trying to do I made a very
mischevous comment the other day where I
said actually I said all these Brands
like you know Prada okay Max Mara I said
they're not really luxury Brands because
they're taste said you know which
suggests that you still care what other
people think I said the only real luxury
brand to me is just Versace where you
just go I'm minty and I don't care who
knows
it and there's an element to me which
says that are you genuinely really
really rich and successful if you're
still agonizing about other people's
appreciation of your own taste
or or is there actually a certain
Freedom that comes with vulgarity you
know I always think everybody would have
a hot tub deep down wouldn't they okay
the only obstacle to having a hot tub is
middle class angst about you know taste
and discernment and all you know and all
that and she being middle class a
massive disadvantage because of course
you're massively worried about what
other people think of you which I
suppose both both very Posh people and
workingclass people are far Freer to
pursue their own enjoyment without
endless concern for the opinion of
others H everybody wants a you know yeah
they should
yeah you know that it intrigues me
actually because um you know the
obstacles you know one of the things I
always say that marketing often makes a
mistake it asks how can we persuade
people to do this I go don't know before
you start doing that look at what are
the obstacles to doing it and see if you
can remove any of
them and that it stries me that the
removal of negatives is actually
probably more potent in terms of
Behavioral change than heaping on kind
of claims
positives and it's right you know there
are really interesting things that
emerge when you look at it backward so
every time I meet Coke I always make
this point that coke has this UT which I
mean the drink okay Coke has this
utterly magical property which is you
can AR it absolute everywhere without it
seeming weird and if they haven't got it
it's their fault not yours okay now when
you think about how rare that is that's
kind of true of water just about okay
but you can go to a Misha St restaurant
you can ask for a Diet Coke you can go
to a beach Shack in Barbados you can ask
for a Diet Coke you can go to an African
shanty town and they've got Diet Coke
and as you ask for it by the way there's
no possible kind of aoam or
embarrassment that's you know comes
cross
now you know if you went to a m Star
Restaurant and asked for Dr Pepper which
is you know not all that right the whole
thing is going to be f with
embarrassment awkwardness you know no
expectations so
on is it is just really really
interesting when you understand that the
extent to which of course human behavior
is mediated by the imagined opinions of
others there great quote from I think
Abraham Lincoln where he made the point
which was also made um by the way by the
same who was the guy you all know the
guy who performed that extraordinary
experiment where people pretended to be
prismas and pretended to be Stanford
Stanford experiment the Stanford yeah
the same academic who did that
experiment also did an experiment with
his own pupils where he just told them
to go on the subway and asked people to
give up their seat with no visible
disability and the point of the
experiment was not to see how many
people gave up their seat it was the
fact that the majority of students came
back and just said I'm sorry I'm
quitting that I can't stand this anymore
that the act of asking someone for their
seat on the subway was just so socially
embarrass embarrassing transgressive and
weird that they experienced something
not other likee pain and and Abraham
Lincoln's part was I think sightly more
sort
of probably different 19th century um
take on this was if you asked to walk
around your town wearing your wife's
Bonnet you know without being able to
explain that it was for a bet or a
charity or something like that you would
experience just extraordinary
pay I first it's it's kind of
interesting because what these social
norms do and I was talking to David slen
Wilson that day who's an evolutionary
biologist is of course when you
establish social norms and conventions
of that kind it changes the nature of
evolution so that it doesn't only happen
at the individual level it's not just a
matter of individual selection it
becomes a matter of group
selection because our Behavior innately
has become conditioned by group dynamics
not by individual
self-interest yeah so there's I think I
think his R proponents by way I'm GNA
you know all half my um doist friends
are going to disown me at this point but
David's a kind of fan of multi-level
selection where he believes that
selection and effectively takes place at
concentric different levels of both the
individual and the uh you know and and
then the family and then the wider group
and there's a kind of level of cultural
selection I don't know why Dar
interesting I don't know why darwinists
hate the suggestion that Darwinism might
work in multiple ways but they uh the
gene centered view seems to sort of
predominate
anyway
interesting hey guys it's if you're
looking for a way to increase longevity
reduce inflammation and brain fog and
anxiety and improve your health and
you're into biohacking and you haven't
tried saing you're missing out on what I
believe is the easiest way to detox and
feel better obviously you can't sauna
out bad lifestyle choices so you still
need to monitor what you eat exercise
Etc but you kind of can at least it's
better than doing nothing so even a
regular person who doesn't care what
they eat of which I have many friends
like that little bit jealous of them but
they can also benefit from saing Bond
charges infrared sauna blanket is what I
use when I'm traveling or not at home it
works just like a big infrared sauna
it's built in but it's portable easy to
clean and easy to store they ship
worldwide and if it doesn't meet your
expectations their returns policy has a
30-day trial and a solid 12-month
warranty go to bond charge.com slmp use
code MP you can say 15% off that's b o n
c h r
g.com MP and use code MP for 15% off
check the link in the comments and
description enjoy the rest of this
episode um what are your what are your
thoughts on the like ethics of marketing
like the the more I learn about
marketing the more I realize well okay
for instance this is what happened to
like my family in the last couple weeks
so dad put out his new book and then a
couple weeks ago
it turns out one of the quotes on the
book that was a very positive quote was
written by someone who had written this
incredibly negative review and the book
like it was just a toxic review and the
book publisher had taken two half
sentences melded them together and put
her name on his book obviously she
wasn't happy about that we had no idea
that was going on and when we approached
the publisher they said oh we do that
for everyone it's just the norm no I
mean there was a famous case of a London
play where the um the cast effectively
just played for the audience were
playing for Applause all the time and
apparently an absolutely horrible play
because the cast would just basically
Applause hungry and someone wrote an
absolutely dabbing review which ended
with with which basically described as
one long Curtain Call and two weeks
later above the theater one long call
was posted along the billboard Marquee
now unly reate I mean uh it is
absolutely possible to mark it
unethically uh it's perfectly possible I
think to mark it unethically without
being aware you're doing so I do hope
that things like Behavioral Science make
it easier to spot dark patterns as you
might call it and that's that's an
extraordinary trick I can't believe they
do that for everyone because it seems to
me to risk reputation embarrassment upon
the public well it certainly did in this
case it didn't go well at all it was all
over the news everywhere and we're like
we didn't we didn't ask for like fake
reviews but apparently it's normal it's
like that's
lying no no certainly grotesque
misrepresentation I mean you know I mean
you know totally totally artificial
selection of data I mean to some extent
of course all advertising is to some
extent a distortion of an already
distorted reality in the sense that
advertising comes from the Latin adim
adver which is to direct someone's
attention to and what you generally do
is you you you direct the attention of
the um viewer or the audience to that
aspect of the product in which it has a
comparative advantage over its
competitors and by A peculiar quality of
psychology whereas logically we should
pay attention to what's important
actually the process works in Reverse we
think important what attracts our
attention that certainly explains the
news cycle okay because you have this
awful problem I think in the news cycle
where effectively news generates its own
news now you know if you take a case but
I I do not condone the kiss of the
Spanish fa um uh uh head at all I think
it was an atrocious act okay right so
I'm not condoning the guy he obviously
must be a very unpleasant guy because
the only person who defends him is his
own M okay but equally at the same time
I don't think it warrants the colum Ines
that it it it's currently get you know
there's a war in Ukraine and we're
talking about you know freeze framing a
video to determine now you know I you
know also important by the way because
there's an interesting question there
which is the only person who can really
determine and judge that act is the
woman herself okay because there are
relationships and contexts in which that
is an acceptable thing to do and and
cultures instead it's a bit weird
actually I don't know I don't know how
North Americans reacting to this because
it's more normal to kiss on the lips
people with whom you're not romantically
engaged in North America apparently than
it is in
Europe oh my gosh I can't imagine most
extraordinarily okay um Ronald Reagan
kissed the Queen Mother on the lips okay
when they met and she was actually
horrified because no one had done that
since her late husband but to a
Californian of that era Reagan who I
venerates so I'm not I'm not having a
dig you know okay uh um but do
California that era that wasn't that
weird a thing to do apparent I don't
know so there's a whole cultural aspect
to it there's also a relational aspect
to it and so the only person who can
really speak meaningfully about that act
is the person to whom it was done
because yeah to everybody else we're
really just bringing our own prejudices
to the party so it's quite it's quite
interesting in that respect but it
certainly doesn't want the Press
attention it's been getting you know
it's absurd okay and so you have this
thing where we deem important those
things which attract our
attention uh you know in other words
things it's something that works
backwards in a way you know that that um
we don't actually pay attention to
what's important we're just as likely to
deem important there's a great line in
Citizen Cane where Kane says make the
headline big enough and I'll make the
story big
enough um that um and actually by the
way most media bias works that way it
doesn't work people who are trying to
call out media bias always talk about
the opinion that is attached to a story
but the greater part of media bias is
actually the prominence that's attached
to the story
okay now to put it another way I think
if you'd had three newspapers in
collusion
you could have buried
Watergate okay you could have reported
Watergate put it on page five and
everyone would have gone yeah they're
all at it
whatever right yeah you know so the
greater part of media bias manifests
itself in where in in what is is what is
given prominence not in what opinion is
attached to the reporting of
events and you know I I see obvious
cases where um you know there is
extraordinary selectivity in which
stories to pursue and which to downplay
um that's for sure uh you know and you
know there are large you know if you're
a middle-aged old blo like me there are
a large number of stories where you just
get I I don't really get this you know I
just don't you know I don't you know
what why is this even the story you know
but but but it is interesting because
obviously now this is interesting
because you there's one way of looking
at at this which is it distorts
perception okay okay because by making
someone look at something differently
they appraise it differently like the
Jesuit priest okay yep it's absolutely
fine to pray while you're smoking okay
and they arrive at a different
judgment but then if you accept that
there isn't a single objective right
answer to the question of which air
fryer should I buy
okay um you I by the way one of the most
extreme cases of this was I nearly
bought a Tesla because had dog mode okay
so dog mode is where you can leave your
dog and stop pet activist smashing your
car windows on the assumption that
you're dog in a car in a car par in
scotdale Arizona when you approach the
car the screen displays a big picture of
a dog and says uh I'm comfortable at a
temperature of 702 degrees fit my owner
will be back soon okay to stop activist
smashing your car window yeah because
they assume if the engine isn't running
in the early days of electric cars uh
people wouldn't have ploted the fact
that the air conditioning could work
while the car was
silent now what was weird is I always
born at Tesla for that reason Lear I
don't even have a
dock here's here's the Counterpoint to
this which I think is interesting okay
now I only discovered this concept A few
weeks ago while reading about Berard de
Manderville who is the world's most
interesting and mischievous Economist
from I think the early 18th century and
he wrote I think all the fable of the
bees which suggested that effectively
private vices Amalgamated to public
goods that it was actually extravagant
self the precursor of Adam Smith in some
ways and you know was an influence on
later economics because he understood
that individual self-interest could um
trans mography into a collective benefit
effectively there's this concept called
mandilion intelligence which is that the
aggregate of lots of different silly
people actually adds up to something
intelligent okay democracy is a kind of
mandilion intelligence that that you
know that some forms of foolishness
cancel out some you know but if you have
lots of different people buying a thing
for different reasons at the level of
the marketplace you end up with much
better products that if everybody bought
a car according to a formula of fuel
econ divided by you know multiplied by
maximum speed divided by cost or
whatever okay if you had a single
rational way of buying cars cars would
actually be awful because they'd all be
optimized for four or five dimensions
and they'd end up being really ugly or
really dangerous or something else okay
because the things we weren't optimizing
for would effectively get neglected the
fact that people all choose to buy cars
for a different uh panoply of totally
nutty you know Americans kind kind of ke
on the number of cup holders on you
you're Canadian sorry par that one but
but North Americans are you know seem to
be much more interested than Europeans
in the number of cup holders and so on
that's funny but where when you
amalgamate all those different
preferences you arrive at a market which
has a kind of collective intelligence
kind of aggregate intelligence Mandan
intelligence now what worries me oddly
is new internet enabled markets where we
all choose the same way okay and I talk
about my my concern is I have a really
major concern with property websites
because everybody goes place number of
bedrooms price high low and then they
search right yeah now the all because
everybody's actually effectively doing
elimination by attribute in the same
order okay this is going to lead to
Absolute absurdities in the property
Market which it does by the way because
apparently you can't sell a haris for
£850,000
okay because people are either searching
800,000 an AR or 900,000 down and they
won't find you till too late or the
900,000 people think they're a bit too
cheap and the 800,000 people think
they're a bit too expensive so you don't
have a price demand curve you have a
kind of price demand zigurat in the
housing market but also architectural
quality architectural quality is
ludicrously under prioritized yes
right because you end up with a choice
of six houses and you buy the least ugly
one right now my argument is now there
are two websites in the UK there's the
modern house.net there's also Inigo
Inigo sells kind of classically
beautiful homes you know from Victorian
Georgia Etc and the modern house is
obviously as it says the modern house
there's also by the way a website in
North America called right on the market
which simply lists Frank Lo right homers
which of that's cool
W okay now now the interesting thing
there is that it's a different it's a
different approach to the state it what
it's doing is it's directing attention
to Aesthetics rather than location price
square
footage and it strikes me that those
websites are a very necessary corrective
because if we all choose in the same way
the market will become stupid and houses
will become uglier yes and so now if you
have if you have the modern house.net
there is a greater incentive to actually
build a fantastic modern piece of
architecture because you actually know
you might be able to sell it whereas if
you go to right move I don't know what
the Canadian equivalent is you know
moose.com or okay but you know if you go
to the Canadian equivalent okay um then
uh you know effectively you know the
equivalent of right move nobody's going
to find the likelihood that someone who
loves modern architecture finds a modern
hat
is actually as i j you said imagine if
we B up that way okay if we said I want
something 6 feet by three and mostly
blue with a bit of green um portrait not
landscape and it want I wanted to
feature two cows and a goat okay and
then your art dealer came out and I said
I've got these three okay well in that
world picassos would be really
cheap because nobody ever found them
because nobody's going in and saying you
going to let a prostitutes in AV of you
where they're kind of wearing Africa
bu no one's ever going to ask for that
okay so the danger is that the unas for
component of the product becomes
ludicrously devalued and deprioritized
yeah whereas a few fairly arbitrary
criteria then dominate in the decision
so there's another argument I'll make
which is an interesting one now bear in
mind I'm giving Pro marketing
advertising answers I also have some
anti- ones
I think the housing market will be much
more effective if all real estate agents
listed negatives by the way yeah because
if it were mandatory that any major
negatives listed people like me who
didn't care about certain negatives will
be able to find a bargain by finding a
house next to a pup you know to 90% of
people the house being next to a pup is
a source of disturbance I mean to me
that's a positive boom okay now you know
the ability to actually navigate the
housing market where you look for things
which are devalued by other people but
are irrelevant to you would be an
additional efficiency in the housing
market but instead real estate agents
just list the
positives one exception Roy Brooks in
the 1960s and 70s who wrote incredibly
rude um patronizing reviews of the
property he had to sell and then put
them in the Sunday typ it was a complete
um completely you can research him um
broel in pimo is um a collection of his
various property Investments which are
all a list of negatives
effectively very very interesting
advertising approach by the way but but
actually the there's another interesting
thing which we never mention which is
that competitive capitalism through
serving a load of desperate needs okay
completely without anyone intending it
creates a form of
resilience that you don't get in a
control
economy so it prevents if you like if a
whole industry is optimized around
certain things it it acquires
vulnerabilities
dependencies uh you know because it's
over optimized for efficiency and
therefore under now the very fact that
you know this is okay this is a
mischievous suggestion so bear with me
okay but if doctors were allowed to
choose their own surgical masks okay we
wouldn't have had a mask shortage right
of surgical masks are bought by
bureaucrats who have some some sort of
flaming stupid bureaucratic you know SN
254 standard three okay and they all B
the same place and it turned out there
was a shortage of the machines not not
of the Mas but of the machines that
could staple the elastic oh now if now
the interesting thing is if marks had
been a fashion item and some people had
gone around with their cath Kinston
floral masks and other people that had a
new mask okay now the mask in industry
as a whole would be less efficient most
of the time but it would also be a lot
more resilient because you'd end up with
M multiple suppliers effectively serving
disperate consumer needs which as as an
unintended byproduct of that activity
actually creates a kind of resilience
and ability to adaptability within the
market anything that's traded as a
anything that's traded as a commodity
becomes basically it just becomes
aace to the bottom on a kind of price
quality scale we just meet we meet the
lowest possible definition of quality
okay at the lowest possible price and I
don't know what is like in Canada but
milk was kind of traded this way now the
problem is is that when you're trading
as a commodity there's no incentive to
incentivize because you don't have a
brand to which superior
quality draws customers and so the
feedback mechanism between quality of
experience and repeat purchase doesn't
this is why the Soviet Union had this
huge problem because yeah why why would
you make any good bread because the only
thing you had to bear was the cost of
making better bread there was no
material reward in terms of people
choosing your bread over somebody
else's and when I have Brands as
effectively the unit of selection of um
product purchase actually capitalism
doesn't really work very well uh you
know you don't actually get much
innovation
H I think we overlooked that I think we
overlooked the central role and what was
interesting in the Soviet Union is they
thought Brands were UNM Marxist and
tried to do without them but they
eventually were forced to make factories
stamp their Identity On The Rivers
because otherwise if rivets were all
bundled together in a central repository
everybody had an incentive to make as
many rivets as possible at as shitty a
level of quality as they could get away
with yeah so without know without
without that fundamental mechanism as a
unit of selection on which you know
consumer choice and experience operates
uh you you really you really didn't
really have an
economy something you said reminded me
of dating apps so you were talking about
the housing market and how people plug
in a certain
number yeah so is that that's happening
the same way right because it's it's
very difficult to judge something like
you can kind of Judge it but it's hard
to judge intelligence uh humor if it's
just six feet and
up you're over undoubtedly overweighting
appearance aren't you
yeah I mean you're you're also
overweighting static appearance by the
way because there are people who are
attractive ENT the way they move yeah as
much as how they look okay uh my wife my
wife is very I find my wife extremely
attractive least photogenic person it's
almost impossible to take a still
photo because she always like put her
hand up or frown or whatever and you
know if I were only presented with still
photographing think I would have we'
been married for kind of 34 years no um
so undoubtedly yeah it's not a it
doesn't it doesn't really practice sort
of mandav Vilan intelligence where
people have different opportunities to
assess your various
virtues and so messy in some senses
messy decision making um
interfaces or or or or processes seem to
lead to better Collective outcomes over
time than decision- making that's kind
of seems to be neat because the of
course the tragic thing is that when
you're looking for a house using that
standard Place price number of bedrooms
Etc okay you're completely unaware of
the things you haven't seen and what's
also interesting about it is talking to
real estate agents or um if you to a
real estate agent they'll say that
everybody comes to the list of
criteria and they know to Discount those
criteria because the majority of people
end up buying a house which meets few or
none in some cases of the initial
criteria they stipulated because they
fall in love with the house for
completely different reasons and the
practice of house buying should be
recursive it shouldn't be a kind of
decision-making
funnel and I think it's one of those
dangerous things which seems rational
while you're doing it because this
stupid element is kept is effectively
hidden from
you yeah
definitely okay and in dating in dating
and dating I think it's highly I think
dating apps are highly problematic as a
choice architecture question yeah and
it's the way they're designed
really well I I got married in 1989 so
as one other person said to me they said
they also got married before dating apps
existed and they said I feel like I
caught the last helicopter out
of yeah well I I think it I think it
really gives like more Psychopathic
people an area to thrive which is just
terrifying interesting yeah my my dad's
figured the same thing because you get
these you know extroverted narcissistic
Attractive people on there and they get
all the attention and the people who are
maybe slightly less attractive but more
attractive in other ways like humorous
smart they get less attention so I don't
know how they even manage dating
apps but I mean one of the important
things is acknowledging that marketing
can be undoubtedly pricious misleading
that there are dark patterns uh should I
think uh one thing behavioral SS can do
and one thing marketers should do by the
way is call it out because it isn't in
the interest of a recable brand for
people to actually
discredit um now an example of this okay
is that the um the whole business of
online subscription to Publications is
such a dark pattern what what Richard
Taylor calls a sludge Affair where it's
very easy to sign up to the introductory
offer it's very easy for them to
suddenly upgrade you to the £99.99 a
month uh full full fee for the subscri
destion that's all very easy but when it
comes to cancelling you've got a phone
up blasted phone line the number for
which is actually very deep on the site
now what those people are doing when
they do that is they are discrediting
and destroying the whole business of
subscription as a mode by which people
might pay for
media yep because essentially you know I
go to be honest I wouldn't mind paying
$4 a month for this and I'd pay $4 a
month in per ity provided I knew I could
cancel on a win uh what these dark
patterns have done I think is they've
actually destroyed the whole yep um
charging mechanism you
know
um I think you know it's you know and
the fact that this isn't called out and
there isn't some sort of kite Mark for
cancellation that's a you know a
promisory method that can and I think
there's legislation going through one I
think it might be the European
Parliament
which basically says that canceling a
subscription must be as easy as
instigating it good um and I think
there's also an issue which is that um
uh it's incredibly difficult to cancel a
recurring credit card
payment uh by calling your credit card
op now this is an interesting one
because I think what what you notice is
they're quite eager for people to
subscribe by credit card because yeah if
you subscribe through a kind of Bank
standing order you can just go to your
online bank account and cancel
them okay yeah it's incredibly difficult
to do the same thing using a credit
card and I think that I think you know I
would favor legislation where recurring
payments on it on your credit card bill
appear at the top are listed separately
and where there's a you know there's a
three click mode of cancelling any of
them and the reason I the reason I'm
saying that is not because I'm a you
know a massive consumer Champion it's
because you know I think that capitalism
when it discredits itself harms far more
people than it benefits and that is a
kind of that's a toxic externality ready
from the practice Yeah I completely
agree I think that's so rampant now like
there's distrust in everything now the
news mainstream media I mean I certainly
don't trust very many marketing ads I
see online that are you know somebody's
review or somebody's quote I'm like
that's probably just manufactured it's
really not good for
everyone where I'll defend this is
working with pretty reputable Brands
over the last 32 years I've never been
in the room where someone suggests
something where I go
Yu more important perhaps I've never
I've never been in the room when someone
suggests doing something where my mom
would have gone Yu okay or my wife who's
a clergy woman would go no no that's
kind of horrible I have heard stories
there was a case long be Cloud nothing
to do with me where someone pointed out
that if you if you change the date at
which bank charges were levied you could
drive more people into a um uh into an
uh uh an overdraft over their overdraft
limit and therefore find them wowow yeah
okay that's crooked now some someone not
a colleague of mine but someone working
in the same industry was in a room that
was suggested now in in defense I don't
think it was implemented but that was
made as a kind of serious suggestion now
that's seriously young and it's very
interesting because um contrary to what
economists think I mean economists have
kind of created a a model of the economy
which is kind of morally neutral and
completely
auman okay you know in other words
they've reduced it to a kind of
mathematical model of efficiency which
uh all psycholog is basically banished
from economics it's reduced to a kind of
artificial Newtonian
problem and uh as a result they' kind of
bypass questions like ethics or indeed
just perceive fairs okay very very
interesting here's a very interesting P
thing if you're interested in this
there's a paper written in 69 about John
lck which is
called venditio
and it's not a question which used to
absolutely bedevil kind of actually um
the church okay the notion of the just
price and he makes a very interesting
assertion which is that to challenge
what something is worth to you
subjectively so he said imagine you have
a horse okay and the hor is really on
the open market uh only worth three or
four pounds but you're very fond of this
horse so You' be reluctant to part with
it for Less than5 it is perfectly
ethical for you to demand 5s for the
horse because that's the compensation
that you would accept to hand over the
horse if however someone is absolutely
desperate for a horse he doesn't really
explain why lock but let's assume they
they're desperate to visit a dying
relative okay and they say I'll pay you
anything you like for your horse
ethically you should charge them5 for
the horse because that's what you'd sell
it for under other circumstances if
however you take advantage of their
perceived distress and ask them for £25
knowing that that's what they would pay
in extremists that's unethical
pricing it's a very very interesting
distinction because I think as human
beings that's how we see it the Char you
know charging a reasonable amount of
money for something when the person is
effectively free to take it or leave it
we regard as basically Fair taking
advantage of another Misfortune to
profit yeah now what's interesting is
that Walmart effectively I don't know if
the people at Walmart read John L okay
but Walmart very interestingly when you
have a hurricane or when you have a
massive snowfall no they do not increase
the prices of shovels okay and they
don't increase the prices of nails and
bits of wood that you bang on your
windows instead what they have is they
have a hurricane prediction center which
ships enormous quantities of show sh
snow shovels to the areas where they're
required and they then sold the
effectively the just
price okay and Walmart knows what
economists don't
know which is that if you gouge
customers and exploit their
predicament they're not your customers
anymore because we react to that as
humans not as economists do by going
more naturally there's an imbalance in
supply and demand so we must you know I
would expect to pay five you know $50
for a plastic snow shovel that's how an
economist would think was a perfectly
reasonable solution to the problem most
non-economists don't think that's fair
as Richard sailor said about Ski Resort
pricing uh basically if you gouge them
at Christmas they don't come back in
Spring and so in the attempt to kind of
to create this kind of reductionist
Economics a whole facet of things that
basically make us human and were
probably essential in the environmental
in The evolutionary environment for
actually our functioning as a social
species have been completely
neglected and of course the road of
reputation is interesting too because
you know a very large part of um uh
economic success is that down to trust
in other words you know do people trust
you to fulfill your promises okay and of
course economics again has frozen that
out of the equation by assuming complete
trust no information as symmetry perfect
information okay and it achieves a kind
of mathematical neatness at the price of
making assumptions which are utterly
ridiculous literally assuming conditions
that never pertain in the real
world and that strikes me as a you know
pretty given the influence of the
discipline that strikes me as a fairly
horrific thing to do yeah because you
only need your model to deviate from
reality in very small ways for the whole
model to become worthless but we seem to
have created a world where people's
attachment to their models of the world
their allegiance to a particular way of
thinking um is somehow tied up with
their identity which is a is a terribly
and you see it by the way on the right
with neoliberal economics you see it on
the on the left with
wokery but the unwillingness to
actually hey to provide some degree of
mental Hospitality to ideas which might
cause you to revise your particular
expect ations or your belief set strikes
me as very very weird and comparatively
a bit recent really I you know I mean
it's interesting question as to maybe
maybe there always be aspects of this
there have always been kind of
bipartisan Tendencies and politics but
it does seem to have got a bit worse I
think it's gotten worse I not that I
have vast amounts of experience over
vast periods of time but that that
reminds me of the the university system
part of the reason we're doing this
Peters Academy project is because the
University Systems really bothered me um
morally with how much it's charging for
a degree that doesn't necessarily lead
you to a job you want and in the US like
I'm from Canada and it's less insane
there but then us it's asadi
universities what's happened with
particularly the IV League okay now
think of it like this okay the if you
want to talk about luxury goods as we
talked earlier about Hermes and Louis V
and so forth the greatest luxury goods
manufacturers of the lot are the
American IB league universities which
maintain scarcity despite the fact that
technology means that actually the
teaching they provide need no longer be
scarce yeah they're really real estate
businesses with a pedagogical
sideline but they also exploit an
incredible kind of path dependency in
terms of the career parts of people who
want to go to work for golden sacks or
whatever I don't know why you want to do
that but people seem to want to do that
okay now let me explain there's a really
weird thing that happens in the London
property Market okay it's the most
depressing thing you can do is to be a
very very high-end kitchen fitter in
central London and the reason is you're
brought in okay to install a 120,000
Kitchen in A5 billion pound house okay
and the reason you're installing that
kitchen is to sell the house right
because the house has to look Immaculate
because the people looking around the
house are you know probably Russian
Crooks who've honey tracked the local
demen chbs are selling them a bloody you
know aluminium smelting works for 7 50
they're a bunch of crooks probably but
they're they're demanding of perfection
and they just wouldn't buy a house if
the kitchen was a bit Banky now so you
have to install £120,000 kitchen to sell
the house to the Russian oligarch and
his mistress okay but here's the thing
the second they buy the house they rip
the kitchen out and replace it with one
of
their okay so apparently it's
unbelievably depressing because you have
to install this kitchen to an
extraordinary level of anal Perfection
and then you know that six weeks later
you'll be called in to trash the kitchen
and replace it with a slightly different
one because lud Miller didn't actually
like green or something right yeah
now in some ways there's an analogy
there which is the the qualification you
get at a university very rarely
translates into the actual job you do
obviously not through of medicine law
and a few other disciplines okay what
you have to do is to jump through this
prior hoop at enormous expense to prove
your employability and to make yourself
salable even though for years in Goldman
Sachs don't care what degree you got a
some wasn't Goldman Sachs you know aome
you know aome at what point in your
career now they said the value of my
double first in maths from Cambridge
basically in my employment had a half
life you know it probably never dips
down to complete relevance it's
something you know a bit like
radioactive decay but they said
basically F five years into my job
everybody wanted to know what I'd done
who i' worked for you know how I equ
myself and oh yes by the way you've got
a degree okay but the time you first get
accepted and this is where the path
dependency comes
in that degree is all they've got to go
on so it's exactly like the kitchen it's
done for display purposes not for its
long-term long-term residual
value because you know what you learn
University largely becomes irrelevant
you know within a very short time of you
starting work it becomes less and less
relevant but it's necess to make the
sale not to improve the house and it
strikes me that education's become a
little bit like that which is actually
the way it should so we have at ogal v a
program called the pipe which is
specifically designed to be a
non-graduate recruitment program because
we think that the obsession with
graduate recruitment is effectively at
the collective level spurning 50% of the
population who may have very very great
talents which just don't manifest
themselves yeah in academic ways but
they're very very bright people in
advertising who if you give them
something theoretical to do they'll lose
interest immediately but if you give
them a real world problem they manifest
uh you know uh displays of Genius you
know there certain people who just hate
theoretical you know you know that
you know okay and those people are not
very well treated by the
academic um proxy metric of your
intellectual capability by the way
the way I'd argue it okay is that
academic ability is a one-way indicator
okay if you're very good academically
you're probably quite bright okay if
you're not very good academically it
does not mean you are not bright now
just to give an analogy which is a clear
thing which everybody understands chess
is like that okay if you're a really
good chess player in some respect you're
quite clever okay but it would be
monstrously unfair to say that bad chess
players are stupid okay my brother's an
astrophysicist he's at jet he's not
as as I am I do cryptic crosswords
I do cryptic crosswords till the cows
come home I can't I just can't mentally
I just don't understand why youd want to
play you know I mean you know I I I
think of you know virtually anything I'd
rather
do but this is the interesting thing
it's a one-way proxy measure which works
in One Direction but doesn't really work
in the other so discounting people who
who have poorer qualifications is not
necess necessarily a safe
decision but then what happens is we
offer these people a job that we don't
prevent people who've got a degree from
applying to the course that would be
silly we just say that this is a a you
know a mode of entry into ogbe where you
can go from there to being chief
executive if you're talented up okay
there's you we don't have any
qualification barriers once you're
employed um and so what happens is we
then offer occasionally we offer a job
to someone who has got a
degree and they say I'm really
uncomfortable at accepting this and you
say why it's you know it's it's an
entry-level job in advertising for God's
sake you know they're Oxbridge graduates
who fail to get that you know what the
hell are you complaining about game and
they say because I've just spent £27,000
getting a degree and if I then go on to
get a job which doesn't require a degree
I'll feel I've wasted my money yeah I
it's not supposed to work like that it
should be thanks to the three years I
spent at the UN and blah I was able to
improve my thinking and cognitive Styles
decision making ability to such an
extent that I could impress the people
at over who wanted to give me a job
that's how it should work exactly but
instead it's I paid 27 grand for some
parchment and if the job I get doesn't
require the parchment are being done now
that's not educ that's education as a
positional good it's not education as
absolute good it's not human capital at
all it's just being used as a mechanism
for lazy sortition by you know the
people who do the recruitment who are
probably the people who are mostly to
blame you know those people who go to
one and above we only you know enloy
people from these five universities I
mean those are the people who are really
to blame because they've made it
possible for effectively
universities to profit from their lazy
decision making I didn't consider that
my God they profit I mean if you want a
if you want a Bloody Business that
absolutely kinds it in American
University is for thing to yeah I mean
Louis Von can't even touch
that
wild well that was interesting there's a
Brian Kaplan book called the case
against education which is emphatically
worth reading um uh there are a few
other people who are um there's also an
interesting thing which is that it may
be a misrepresentation by the way
complete meritocracy may be a mistake
anyway because you don't you don't go to
university to be surrounded by a
homogeneous group of similarly nerdy
people um so there are all sorts of
there are all sorts of tough questions
to be asked about this one one
suggestion by the way was that you know
actually the top 20% of IV places should
be allocated on pure meritocracy and the
other 80% should be by
lot
okay um which is kind of interesting um
but we're in danger of creating a kind
of you know effectively an arms race and
uh I I think it's the guy um who's the
philosopher uh at uh Harvard who's
called Michael sandal who describes many
of his pupils as wounded winners in
other words they have actually succeeded
but the price they've had to pay to get
there has had some you know deleterious
effects and Hyper competition is bad by
the way competition is good competition
where you know broadly speaking the
terms of success are quite Broad and
where you can out witht the opposition
through creative thinking okay that kind
of competition is very healthy the kind
of competition which is effectively The
Hunger Games type of competition is
actually bad because actually the the
overall price paid is greater than the
priz well if you include the people who
fail alongside it you ultimately say
look we're actually exacting a greater
price than we are actually conferring a
benefit and there's a very interesting
guy called I think fishbach check his
name he's a
but he argues that the whole concept of
equality of opportunity is wrong and
that what a society should aspire to
offer is diversity of
opportunity in other words what we've
done to M to produce the illusion of
fairness and
meritocracy is we have to apply the same
criteria to everybody and when you apply
the same criteria to everybody only some
people can win and it turns into a kind
of H games death match if you say what
we want as a society where lots of
people can be successful in lots of
different
ways that's not a negative SU
game and it strikes me that that concept
of of broadening opportunity rather than
actually uh F the other thing is you
might argue which is this wonderful talk
about you know meritocracy and you know
and equality of opportunity equality of
outcome all of that presumes a society
which is
hierarchical because when the term
meritocracy was finded by Michael Young
later Lord young okay he meant it as a
criticism oh so meritocracy is often
used particularly in North America as a
as a term of approbation it's a
meritocracy here yeah okay Michael Young
coined the word in England used it as
basically a warning that in many ways
it's worse being governed by people who
think they deserve to be there okay and
believe themselves possessed of Superior
ability to the people who whom they
govern that it is being governed by
people who you know the kind of slightly
random aristocracy who can't help deny
the fact that they kind of lock into the
oh yeah I like that keep it humble it's
interesting interesting Canadian you'll
understand the value of monarchy which
is that you know there is a value to the
monarchy which is precisely that the
role is
arbitrary yeah and it's and is known to
be arbit
straight that that that's very true yeah
American politics is strange even being
being here is is strange it's very
theatrical in a way that I haven't seen
where are you in the US I'm in the US
now I'm actually in
Scottdale oh wonderful place yeah have
you been to the hotel Valley Ho
fantastic mid-century place I
haven't I go to stay there it's the kind
of place where the Rat Pack would engage
it you know but it but scotdale the
other place you must which I imagine you
have been to have you been to the Desert
Botanical Gardens no not yet right okay
you got you got a book that visit it's
one of my favorite places in the whole
world because now bear in mind I'm
British okay so the very fact I the
reason I love Phoenix okay is that if
you're British a desert is magical
because we live in a country where
there's green all over the place
you got to do is some dirt out in the
street and something goes green on it so
have your hotel room window and having a
cat just a rock and some sound is to is
to me absolutely magical I I Adore the
place and the the botanical gardens is a
fantastic collection of cactus
succulents and if you go I'm really
plugging this face if you go at Su that
you also get the hummingbirds coming in
to feed off various kind of agave plants
or whatever but it's one of the most
enchanting places on the planet really
really fabulous okay I need I need to
check that out and and the other you're
going to do the other do is the Frankl
right tour so you've got the Grady
gamage
Auditorium um you've got a bunch of
houses on the outskirts of Scotsdale
which which are by right and then of
course the other one is tales in West
which is right it's it he he moved in
the winter from Wisconsin tallin and
actually started a kind of architectural
school um uh basically outside
Scottsdale called talas in West that
it's fantastic that's I had no idea Rory
expect me to be the uh key member of the
Arizona tourist Authority no no I didn't
at all I'm I'm a fan it's a bit hot
right now but it's other that are winter
and darkness that's what they say yeah
don't worry it's a dry heat it's 120 but
it's dry like you Liars
[Laughter]
yeah okay Rory thank you very much for
coming on that was fascinating SI
pleasure any time that went way deeper
than I was expecting
[Music]
n